so it became I feel comfortable
comfortable I don't trust the time I
feel like he's hiding something
isn't there something you have to tell
me I had quite the weekend binge
watching some episodes for a 90 day
fiancé before the 90 days so good juicy
stuff for sure and well that you're not
unfamiliar with you're quite familiar
with this world the setting this world
is not something that you are unfamiliar
with I should say you've done you've
been here before and here you are again
this season though with a guy named Tom
yep so we caught up with you I believe
last in October and you told us then
that you trust Tom you have no trust
issues there but then cut to we see the
trailer for the season and you seemingly
say or you don't seemingly say you say
you don't trust Tom in this trailer why
is it the case what changed you know Tom
and I um you know have a unique
situation this time around and he knew
exactly what I was referring to and in
that moment you know I'd been trusting
Tom you know and in that moment there
was something that I felt like he needed
to share with me and he hadn't so I
wanted him to to open up about it and I
just put him on the spot in that moment
I'm maybe to try to catch him off guard
because I wanted to see how he was going
to respond to what I was asking him so
yeah you knew how I felt about that and
it hurt but he did answer very honestly
was it what you wanted here no but you
know that's okay I accept that now and
we've talked about that so okay so
communication is obviously something
that is extremely important for any
relationship be it you live in the same
county city town state a Jase you know
country country yeah uh and here you are
in a relationship with a guy who lives
over in the UK and it seems like
communication is your number one problem
why do you feel like communications been
so difficult for you in time
actually we did communicate a lot you
know over the span of our relationship
you know the four years I knew we had a
great friend foundation and it really
helped kind of build our you know
relationships together but yeah was
getting a little strained oh the lack of
communication obviously was lacking and
you know we're both busy people busy mom
you know and he travels a lot for his
work and I just felt like you know it
was kind of on his timeline when he
wanted to talk and you know I would
reach out sometimes you know it was busy
or whatever but you know I just I just
felt like I needed more of that openness
with him and you know just tell me how
you're feeling like it's something I
don't want to have to like sit around
and wait and wonder if something's wrong
yeah you're playing the waiting game
yeah I didn't like that feeling it
wasn't a good feeling and he knew he
knew he had to kind of like show me a
little bit more respect than that so
well you've always been you've always
said and you've told us again as well
and around October so that you and your
hearts have always been open to finding
love but you seem to be unlucky in love
a bit so would you attribute that to the
way in which you find love maybe maybe
that's how it's been but I've always
been very open in love they give her a
big heart and you know I do want that
and and you have to wait see to find out
what happens between Tom and I but um
you know I don't I think people see a
different side of me they think that I'm
kind of desperate and then I'm seeking
out for it she desperately but no I mean
my relationships you know with Jesse
even and with with Tom they've been very
real and they you know wanted to be in
the relationship too wasn't one-sided so
you know when I give my heart give it
big and you know they said they loves me
and wanted to be with me and you know I
just felt right but you know in the
you know Jessie was too toxic to stay in
and that's what I kind of opened up the
time I felt like I could trust him and
you know we had that journey and it was
beautiful feeling you know they could
you know be open and to fall in love
with somebody that you know has your
back in a sense you know could yeah
maybe maybe I am a little unlucky I love
I guess in that moment yeah let's do it
just know assessee attitude please what
did I do now
so you mentioned Jessie you know what's
the biggest lesson you feel like you
learned from that relationship with
Jessie ah the biggest lesson I learned
is to hold her power and not give it
away in a relationship you know and love
yourself first two years two years I was
you know I knew at the end it was it was
dying out you know I needed to and for
me and for my kids cuz I didn't want to
keep going through that cycle you know
it was very yeah I was hunting off and
no actually when he came to break up he
manipulated me basically said you know
I'm coming in the name of lovey I knew
my god I knew something wasn't right and
I I was ready to walk away at that point
to be honest with you said I think you
just wanted the last day with less word
so but I walked away and I'm doing
amazing though today yeah that's
wonderful news now what about with Tom
what's been a lesson learned there with
Tom yeah I mean I have you know a lot of
respect for you know the relationship
that we you know have and I think I
learned how to just stay more open and
loving for myself as well you know you
have to you know to receive love you
have to love yourself first you know and
I think telling him what I do want you
know just in general relationships I
feel like it I'm a big yes person time
for me to say no but this time you gotta
say what you want what about your girls
what do they say when you were like gals
I'm going back on the show yeah yeah all
day you know were they cool with it
yeah actually
they were very very accepting of it you
know they just want to see me happy
you've actually helped me chill and
realize what I don't want like you just
click on a chair or light do or be like
those very special you didn't have to do
that
so with all your time on the series
though what has been a regret because
seeing things back you probably had
something that you regret yeah oh yeah
oh yeah so what's that one thing that
you wished she could take Zack probably
the scene after I met Tom you know we
brought a nice fresh straw and you know
I think I got a little too excited and
you know maybe making it seem like I was
ready to you know get intimate right
away with him but I just in that moment
I just felt like I didn't want to sleep
alone you know in in a other room it was
a huge Airbnb townhome I know there was
bedrooms on different floors so I just
you know he was being respectful I
understand but I think it kind of got
you know in that moment I was just you
know we known each other for years I
just wanted to you know write have
someone by my side you know and fall
asleep in his arms you know and then you
go chunks of time without seeing each
other yeah great you want the intimacy
you know are getting more insight into
your real past relationship with Jesse
your current relationship with Tom and
how that's playing out but what about
the relationships you have with your
fellow 90-day fiance co-stars I guess
you could call them what's you is there
a relationship with that family um yeah
I mean I respect them all you know all
the couples have their own unique story
and stuff and everybody has different
personalities but I mean is there like a
group text going on y'all say in close
contact with one another
I've met a lot of them at events and
stuff like that yeah and Annie are
really nice I was excited to do pillow
talk you know with them's and it stays
so we got to meet them for some things
that we did in New York and in LA so you
know sometimes people call and say hi to
check up Russ and how I love them
they're so amazing and their cute little
baby yeah so we always like message each
other or like comment on Instagram
picture
and stuff like that so she's a very
sweet lover Angela Angela we don't
really keep with contact they see on the
table
yeah how long's we just you know kind of
hug it out and say hi yeah a little
chats and stuff so she's she's she's
funny we're always surprised though that
she had Jesse's back in this yes but I
understand where she was coming from and
she had where did you think she was
coming from well I feel like cuz she had
known us from the past season together
so I I think she felt like she wanted to
kind of protect what we did have I guess
in some sense and you know I know Jesse
was back there in the green room or
something really filming our segment
right so you're this commotion going on
and I honestly was just like it's not
worth it like why is everybody like
getting angry about this like I
appreciated Tim for you know standing up
for me and protecting me and Avery as
well you know obviously you could tell
she had been through something you know
toxic in the past you know it triggered
something because it went from zero to
100 like that but then I didn't want
anyone getting hurt
it was just like I came out on on set
and it was like it's not worth it guys
right just like that
please don't worry cool yeah I was
impressed I had to stay strong so I felt
bad for Avery Tim you know it's kind of
my ground but then it's just it was just
too much back and forth too much
negativity and it really wasn't
it really wasn't worth it yeah you know
yeah we all you know are there for each
other as like a family and that's why I
think they stuck up for me but um I
don't know definitely got the drama so
you have been open to love along the way
it's opened you up to some drama in this
whole process and journey you've also
been very open about plastic surgery yep
and I'm sure you receive your fair share
of comments from your fans followers and
spectators or people that watch the show
when people speak out and say you look
unrecognizable from previous clips or
photos that you have posted how does
that make you feel what do you want to
say anything to them if anything
I've always embraced plastic surgery I
don't think there's anything wrong with
it I mean I obviously get Botox and
fillers and I have no shame in that
you know I feel beautiful and signing
out that's all that matters if you can
enhance it a little bit you know to
maintain your youthfulness why not you
know I've gone under the knife you know
a couple times but I feel it was to fix
things that I felt like like after I had
my kids there was extra skin that you
can't you can lose all the weight you
want but you can't lose that so you know
I just wanted a more contoured shape and
you know you got to set healthy limits
for yourself anyway regardless in life
so I just thought it was time for me to
do me meet you girls I see honey you've
got some you've got a celebrity
following as well
Chrissy Teigen L love Christie she's
amazing she is a ball of energy to say
the least and you guys have actually
hung out together is that great yeah I
got to go to her house just hang in yeah
with the legend yes she's amazing and
yeah you guys do together we did a
commercial together for Hulu it was some
other people from other shows there
which is really great I have a clerk yes
and Jeff and you know Loren and Alexei
were there as well so we all got invited
to go you know for the day it was
amazing
she came downstairs all beautiful and
she when she saw me I was like the last
person I think she saw and then Garcia
she embraced me out to me and she said
something really beautiful that touched
my heart she said I really you know look
up to you in the way that you also
raised your daughters I think they're
amazing kids you raised them well and
that touched home yeah yeah it's got to
yeah because she was really sweet and
that said you're always welcome to
Connecticut so yeah she welcomed in her
home and she's always welcome tours
there are rumors that you and your
sister C are getting your own spin-off
series is that correct you've heard
those rumors I've heard the rumor and
but I don't know it's happening I don't
happen to give it to a straight girl it
would be a great opportunity I would
love
if it did happen so you know we'll see
what the future holds what would you
love for it to focus on if you had the
chance to have a spinoff if we were to
have one just who we are as people our
family life you know maybe some you know
love stories yeah
and finally to finish things do you have
a favorite couple or or person that has
been showcased in the franchise um so
yeah I'm actually I'm really excited to
see the new couple and before 90 days
they're the first gay couple I think
that's really amazing and groundbreaking
it's gonna be an amazing season it's
gonna really reach a lot of people and
you know bring new things to light yeah
I cannot wait to see it oh yeah already
I mean I had some access to the mixer it
says yeah so goodly Duff I know and good
luck on your journey thank you I'll
always appreciate it and keep my eye on
the prize
[Music]
you